Louis Pelchat-Labelle.
- La production de moutarde
de Marjolaine Legros est
présentement arrêtée.
Les comptoirs sont libres,
les étagères, presque vides.
Même si le Canada est
le deuxième producteur mondial
de moutarde, la sécheresseuit
une grande partie des récoltes
en 2021. Pour la moutardière,
c'est le réchauffement
climatique qui est à blâ proprie
des Moutardes Legros
- Le changement climatique,
beaucoup n'y croyaient pas, mais
là on est dedans. Des 50 degrésé
dans les provinces de l'ouest,
ils n'avaient jamais vu ça.
On regar
Europe, ils y goûtent aussi, là.
- Les Moutardes Legros n'en
problèmes d'approvisionnement.
Ce printemps, c'est le miel
qui a manqué pour pouvoir
Ces nombreux bris dans
la chaîuction
inquiètent notamment l'Union
des producteurs agricoles.Prés..
de l'UPA Gaspésie-Les-Îles
- C'est c'est
inquiétant. Je veux dire,
peu importe que ce soit
dans les blés, que ce soit...
c'est dans toutesns toutesns tos
les productions. Présentement,
les bris sont assez importants.
des fournisseurs, quand ils
nt, ils peuvent avoir
jusqu'à 25 % de réduction
de stock.
son conjoint font tout, de latr.
Mais avec les récents problèmes,
le couple se demore la peine.
- C'est une situation qui est
inquiétante, qui demande à
réflexion. On fait quoi?
On arrête-tu toutje ne veux pase
pessimiste, il faut être
réaliste aussi.
cette histoire de moutarde peut
anodine, pour Madame
Legros, cette rupture dans
la chaîne d'approvisionneme
Ici Louis Pelchat-Labelle,
Radio-Canada, Newanada, Newanal